what we're thinking about now is
a common language for characterizing
different data sets let me say that
again shape and modality they're they're
a common set of vocabulary that so long
as you can know what these words mean as
soon as someone says it you don't need
to use a long awkward phrase to describe
what a data set is like you can just say
oh it means this and we all know what
you're talking about okay so we're going
to talk about each of these in turn
actually going to do it backwards so
let's start with modality you might want
to put this kind of in the middle of
your page because we're going to have a
few things branching off it okay
this idea of modality
as you might guess from the name it's
connected to the mode right tell me
again what the mode means
the most occurring score the most
frequently occurring the most common
score okay so the modality is about well
how many of those are there
how many modes are there in your data
now so far we've been looking at and
even the one i just gave you this
morning um so far we tend to look at
data which has just one mode
one
mode so very originally we call that
uni
modal like a unicycle right so if
there's just the one mode there's just
one score that's more common than all
the rest that's it and this is what you
often encounter so no big deal i don't
think it warrants much more explanation
it's the other two which i want to think
about a bit more and i'm going to ask
you in a second i've got my own ones but
i'm going to ask you in a second to help
me work out some practical examples of
this because they're all over the place
it commonly takes place that there isn't
just one mode there isn't one dominant
score okay
often there's like two so instead of
being unimodal again be original and
creative instead of being unimodal you'd
probably call this
if there's two
bimodal right well you're actually
jumping ahead of me so we'll get to that
a bit later so bimodal means there's two
modes okay now in all kinds of data and
i'll give you a really easy i'll give
you like the classic really boring
example but it's the textbook one so i
need to tell you
a set of data if you have a look the one
we actually just had a look at is not a
bad instance of it
will have naturally occurring at two
most like high peaks in the data right
so if you wanted to draw unimodal data
it might look something like this
biomodal data might look something like
this
it's worth pointing out they don't have
to be like exactly equal to each other
right
they might be off just by like a few
scores but if you can see there's like a
big obvious peak here and there you're
like okay there's two modes
the classic example is the one we just
looked at it's heights if you have a
look at a population right and just
overall just say hey let's look at
everyone even in this room in this
school you're naturally going to get two
peaks and those two peaks represent a
structure in the data that we actually
haven't talked about why might there be
in a room like this or in a school like
ours
two peaks to the data
boys and girls right so you're like okay
if you've got boys they're generally
taller if you're girls they're generally
shorter so this is why i mean obviously
there's outliers to both of those
but you often see this kind of thing
okay
can someone give me a different example
so we just talked about heights
right and by the way it's super
important that you mention these
examples they're an actual thing you
have to learn in the syllabus we've
mentioned heights in a um you know if
we're not looking at gender can someone
think of another time or another place
where you naturally end up getting two
peaks in the data
traffic fantastic
traffic is another classic example
because throughout the day there tend to
be two peak times for when there are a
lot of cars on the road and you can tell
me what those peak times are right again
there's a structure in the data what are
the peaks
yeah morning commute people going to
work school
and then afternoon evening commute
people coming home it is worth pointing
out traffic i'll put like an asterisk on
this one because we might come back to
this one in a second okay
i'm the kind of person who feels hungry
all the time so there's a bimodal set of
data that comes with hunger right if you
run a restaurant if you run a restaurant
and you look at the times that your
restaurant is busy
when are the two peaks going to be
lunch and dinner right so we might say
meal times
are going to increase the amount of
business at a restaurant assuming it's
not one of those like 24-hour type
things okay even in a 24-hour restaurant
you're still going to get peaks of some
kind okay
so buy modal tata all the time now i
think if i heard right it was said but
it might be someone else so i apologize
if someone else said this when there's
more than two when there's just like a
whole bunch of different modes we would
say that's
multi-modal so this is the third kind of
modality that we need to have a look at
now again they don't have to be exactly
the same height even if they're roughly
right you can clearly see there are some
peaks you will get these kinds of things
occurring so
i'll give you an example and then i want
to see if you can think of your own one
okay if we went out to
i don't know we live in this area if you
went to cumberland forest right who's
been to cumberland for us before by the
way it's in west penn hills now if you
if you haven't been go there it's
beautiful okay if you go to cumberland
forest or any forest for that matter and
you start measuring the heights of
plants
just every plant you see you measure its
height from the ground okay you're going
to gr get a graph like this i'm just
going to write this right tree heights
or plant heights might be a better way
to say
why do you think you will get a bunch of
different peaks
now josh and you've been giving me some
really good suggestions so far i wonder
if anyone else can help me out before i
go to you guys rishi what do you reckon
plants don't follow any rules right so
you are gonna get like a big spread like
this there's not a behavior i guess that
comes with it however that while it's
true doesn't account for why there are
peaks because they like could just be
random right it could just be like
pretty even josh what do you think
different pieces of plants don't grow
nice okay i mean i'm biased because i
went to an agricultural school but come
on people you all study a little bit of
agriculture if you've got a
sort of i was gonna say branch wrong
word if you've got like a little bracket
of heights in here right that all
cluster around a certain height there's
like a mode in there they're probably a
certain kind of plan right like grasses
are going to grow up to a certain height
and then no more they'll stop right and
then you can see you just look out the
window you can see some of the gum trees
different kinds of gravillas whatever
okay they're going to represent each of
these different
i give up on this one each of these
different modes okay so you've got
species can you give me another one
another time where you get multimodal
data
this one's a bit tricky isn't it oh yeah
what do you reckon
say it again
paige
what makes you think that i'm just or
anyone like why might that be something
that we include in here
why might we get brackets of ages
yeah what do you think different
generations
okay so for example if you have a
thinker have you guys heard of baby
boomers right you're like okay boomer
right why was there a mode of people
born around 1945 1946 do you guys know
what made the baby boom actually happen
really no 1945 how many people study
history in this room
okay
1945 was the end of world war ii right
and world war ii was really like the
second part of world war one so you had
these decades 1914 to 1918 was world war
one 1939 to 1945 world war ii this whole
part in the middle right there was
scarcity there was concern about safety
all that kind of thing there just were
less children born and then there was a
boom right now there are other things
that cause booms as well so you will get
a bunch of these and they're kind of
there's not just two throughout history
there can be any number of them yes i
think it's a really good pick um i put
an asterisk on this one over here
right i actually think depending on how
closely you look at the data you could
potentially put it in here
can you think of more than just two
things that would make the traffic spike
during the day
okay so you're gonna get like this
there's a in fact this morning um there
is a big traffic jam on the sydney
harbour bridge because it was like a
three-car crash really sad okay so
that's gonna happen but i even thought
of it as you guys were telling it to me
right in the morning it's very likely
you guys will go to school at the same
time as people go to work but in the
afternoon
i mean what time do you guys get out of
here three o'clock do most like
office workers finish at three o'clock
not unless they're very very lucky right
most of them finish at five so you're
actually going to get a different
distinct peak here does this make sense
you can see how multimodal data appears
any questions on that so making sense
okay and we're gonna have to think about
oh yeah josh
yeah yeah yeah absolutely so you can see
um there is this blurriness to thinking
about statistics you know when we were
having a look at what makes an outlier
one and a half into quartile ranges two
and a half standard deviations with
modes i sort of mentioned to you like
these don't have to be at the same
height there's a blurriness to thinking
about statistics that doesn't exist in a
lot of areas of mathematics fun fact if
you go to uni the people who study
statistics statisticians and people
study mathematics they often have very
little to do with each other because
it's a whole different kind of thinking
here it's like is it this one or that
one
it kind of descen depends on us okay one
last question before we go into shape
yeah
is there a mathematical definition to
you're talking about like how like
what's our threshold for how close they
have to be the short answer is no
no
um we will have a look i mean this is
tricky right because then you're like oh
do we have to just rely on human beings
saying like it looks kind of like this
um no we can come up with rules but no
rule is going to be hard and fasting
will apply to all data because all these
forms of data we're just having a look
at have different reasons different
amounts of randomness and that kind of
thing okay